we've been doing a lot we've had a lot
of interactions with with dignitaries
from India we just had the Dalai Lama
here a couple of weeks ago and we're
gonna have Sri Sri Ravi Shankar who is a
very prominent guru who has many many
millions of followers here and we're
talking about Indian issues in
particular of late Sivan and uma is our
resident scholar in Indian studies and
he has a question about that country I
can all this thank you very much I have
a broad question about India when you
look at your engagement with the country
what do you think it's done well and
where do you think it needs to do the
most work well India has a lot of very
socialistic policies having to do it
labor and land and it the fact that it
has not risen as a manufacturing power
is an indictment of of its government
policies that is as China's incomes went
up the place that the world should have
moved to next as the manufacturing of
the world absolute absolutely should be
India and that's only happening to a
very very tiny extent and it has to do
with you know regulatory complexities
infrastructure quality now you know I'm
optimistic about India we put more into
India than any country in the world
India benefits from a funny form of
competition which is competition between
the states and so you know when one
state really gets its act together the
other states tend to feel jealous and
they you know are kind of looking at
what policies led to that the states in
the north that were particularly focused
on Bihar Uttar Pradesh have lagged in
every human development numbers as well
as income but the improvements and we
have a big partnership with Nita
kymaro's chief minister in Bihar the new
chief minister in uttar pradesh decided
that these health things that we care
about he'd get very involved with and so
we're seeing a very fast rate of
improvement their vaccination coverage
and we got polio
the last polio case there was three
years ago which is an amazing triumph
we've taken the
aquatic quality audit group and we've
turned it into a primary health care
audit group that's looking at where
where the workers not show up where the
supply chain not work why don't people
go in his health is very complicated
because they have a lot of these a
private sector that's very low quality
and the government hasn't figured out
how to get the private sector to be high
quality and yet they haven't built the
capacity in the public sector but you
know things climb is on our side in
India it's just frustrating you know
they haven't adopted a few new vaccines
that between there's two new vaccines
that will save over 400 thousand lives
per year in just India alone and they're
being quite slow on that that issue so
India's great and in 15 years you know
we'll probably be out of India because
its budget will get bigger and it
allowed keep more of it to health why
did they what what result the delays and
actually the permitting and what did
that what those two that the virus is
there right the suspicion of but they
the bureaucrats really like the status
quo the way the career system works
you're much better off not to change
things and so getting somebody to say
yes we'd like to spend more money on a
new vaccine knowing that there's a crowd
that's going to come in and attack that
there's a little bit of conservatism and
there's an election coming up hopefully
you know the if you get close to an
exome you get particular paralysis and
the bureaucracy post the election
there's a lot of optimism that things
will both in terms of deregulation and
taking on new health initiatives that
that things will be even more aggressive